depuis hier une soixantaine d'hommes se
sont relayés sur les lieux de l'accident
pour mener en parallèle deux types d'
enquête
les hommes du bureau d'enquêtés et
d'analysés pour la sécurité civile sont
chargés de rechercher les causes
techniques du crash
la gendarmerie elle travaille sur le
volet judiciaire le parquet de besançon
ayant ouvert une enquête pour homicide
involontaire
le but est de rechercher les éléments de
preuve et pour ce faire on se doit de
d'engager des experts en la matière et
c'est pourquoi on fait appel à cette
section de recherches de gendarmerie
transport aérien dans un premier temps
des relevés sont effectués sur place
avant que la carcasse ne soient découpée
puis envoyé morceau par morceau dans les
laboratoires de la gendarmerie ou du bea
en contactant les ateliers de
maintenance de l'avion à caen en
l'occurrence pour ce cyrus 22 ainsi que
le constructeur les enquêteurs de
sécurité tentent de déterminer une
éventuelle défaillance de l'appareil sur
ces petits avions il n'y a pas de boîtes
noires c'est trop petit par contre
aujourd'hui on trouve de plus en plus de
petits systèmes d'enregistrement dans
les écrans d'affichage pour le pilote
et si c'est le cas on essaye de les
trouver en espérant qu'ils soient pas
trop abîmer ou au patro boulot dès ce
soir le travail d'analysé va pouvoir
démarrer et on sait que dans ce type
d'accident
il faut souvent des mois avant de
pouvoir donner des éléments de réponse
qui permettent de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé